As much as I disagree with Kelly Gene on basically everything,
she's honestly a really good person. Like I I think almost pixie
levels of being nice courteous to people. When Jessica was spiraling
in like February, he was leaning on me. So, you know, someone
is not making the best decisions doing I told Kelly I was like,
Kelly, why would you say this publicly? You're like, so I I was
like I I just don't understand what this what this does. This
is so I don't care. Because because the It's so weird. It's just
so weird to be like, "This person was DMing me a whole bunch.
They they came to me when they were like feeling really bad about
certain things going on in their life that were making them like
vulnerable." And I was like, "You know what? It's true when I
tell people this." Oh my god.
And the other topic we had on the stream, this Destiny guy just
loves doxing people like all the time. Always loves it. Uh let
me where where I got that streamable at? There it is right there.
Also, hold on. Just as a quick thing to be clear, okay, for these
little cowardly sucks.
Just to be clear for these cowardly to be clear. To be clear,
one thing I'm really good at, I hate this guy.
Dodging my wife's lies like I'm Neo in the Matrix. Okay. Oh,
my role. I can dodge my wife's lies like I'm like I'm Neo from
the Matrix. We're already on kick only, guys. We didn't even
log off after the end of that stream. We watched a bunch of clips
of like Nick Fentes about Destiny after his divorce. Yeah. Yeah.
Just laughing at the gl
me on my way to gaslight your wife into leaving you and and it
works so good.
It was really funny. Unfortunately, it's really, trust me, we
were shaking our head the whole time being like, "This guy is
horrible. This guy's beliefs are reprehensible." And it's a tragedy
that he's this funny. Okay, it is reallyed Well, that one clip
where he's like, I'm going to force choke Mina Gorin and next
time I see her, I'm going to Meanwhile, Grumpy, thank the eight
months. Thank you. Thank you.
You should ask Dan next time he's if he's being a jackass if
he has the same energy for Ethan doxing the wrong guy when he
was trying when trying to do dox Nick Wick Lee. That's right.
Friend of the stream, Nick Wick Lee.
Ethan's doxing. Yeah, I Well, I remembered Ethan Klein's doxing,
but I forgot that he actually doxed the random or the wrong Nick
Lee.
we went over it. I could go. Unlucky for you, buddy. We're going
over this uh this Destiny clip, but we got through the got to
like the mannerism and it was a little little much. Also, hold
on. Just as a quick thing to be clear, okay, for these little
cowardly sucks. Whose is Copen Seed sucking? Is Becket sucking
here?
I don't even I feel like Beckett has criticism for most of the
same people we would. Like I can't imagine Becket was looking
at the Ethan Klein and being like, "Oh, no. I'm totally on board
with all of this the whole time." But also, this seems an insane
thing for Dan to even argue about considering that Destiny has
called for people's doctors multiple times. I don't even mean
recently. Remember that with the girl who threatened to egg him
on his Why is he Why is he annunciating like this? This is like
a totally reasonable
yeah it's like he's like desperately trying to make it sound
like someone's spazzing out when it's like just someone yeah
aren't these guys like total lying like pieces of don't these
guys just like suck so it's not it's not a a shouting tweet
yeah if you have like any moral consistency at all and you do
a podcast with this guy then why are you complaining
is the point that's just the calm normal rational point university
tour dami sweep this [__] constantly nobody sweeps
when I do When I call people talk, I'm public about it and I
admit it. I'm not I'm not over here like, "Oh, no. That's actually
[__] no. If I'm harassing somebody, you believe I
want them to know that I'm harassing them." Absolutely. What
do you mean? If I If I have that position towards somebody, I'll
tell you why. I'll give you my explanation for it, but I'm going
to sit here and pretend that I don't.
Uh, by the way, never actually backed up any of his attempted
justifications at
Yeah. Hasn't evidenced any of the justifications and also literally
did lie about it for years. It's only now that he literally spurred
the [__] out, could not control himself, lost his
[__] mind during the recent lawsuit stuff and started
doing in such a blatant, unavoidable, stupid way that he he couldn't
do the whole, "Oh, give me an example of we've done this and
I'll handle it." You know, all this stuff's been handled. All
my community, you know, every community has crazy people, but
I always handle it. He can't do the plausible dability game that
he tried for years anymore. Dude, I just realized uh didn't he
literally deny doxing Anna by referencing her? It wasn't actually
related. Hold on. Didn't he literally deny this in the Willy
Mack video?
Hold on, hold on, hold on. Let's uh And he encouraged them to
post in her Oh, okay. Also, heads up. This is my only non media
blackout time. Okay, this is my only non-media blackout time
where Okay, somebody on Kiwi Farms has made a thread of Anna.
So, if you are obsessed with Anna and you want to talk about
her all the time, you chat her. You can actually go to Kiwi Farms
and you can go and post all you want, read all you want that
go there, post about it. The Kiwi Farms that you know is the
rationale to docks and call for the death of certain people,
talk about it. People put a lot of effort into categorizing and
archiving everything. There you go. Okay. And in the thread about
Anna that Destiny encouraged his fans to go message, they docked
Anna in response to this. Anna texted Destiny, "Do it to How
many people around this person can we harass or can we dox or
swat or whatever?" And like that's just the goal this him explaining
why it's bad. Uh it's pretty cringe. It's pretty gross. Uh I
expect the behavior from Kiwi Farms. It is what it is. Like I
said, communities like that will always exist. But it's really
gross when people like Justical um whose information I hope I
can find soon. Uh
are like trying to amplify or put a magnifying glass on for over
there and then have it spread it to the other world. That's just
wild to me. So I asked Destiny about isn't this guy awesome when
he just isn't he so cool when he does that? And this is what
he said. People accusing you of doxing, right? Because you're
referring to Kiwi Farms. Uh Ryan did this with Anna. And then
um Jay Stalk is doing this. Quean is sort. By the way, my point
was never that he doesn't say or that he says he doesn't dox
me. Of course he does. But uh
Oh, and Quimman. Like he he of course he's trying to dox us,
but he says like, "No, not Anna." But no, we just watched the
clip this night that Willie M. doing this where there's DMs about
you saying like, "Hey, I wish this person has this person been
doxed yet."
Yeah, I um for Anna, lol Jtock going to get sued. Uh I Yeah,
go for it, I guess. I don't know what I'd be sued for, Kev. 999
GH, but for just I could I do it. Um but not for Anna. No, we'll
get back to the There we go. Not for Anna. No, there it is. Wow.
We need to get through this. Believe I want him to know that
I'm harassing them. Absolutely. What do you mean? If I if I have
that position towards somebody, I'll tell you why. I'll give
you my explanation for it, but I'm going to sit here and pretend
that I don't. Okay. Like a little [__]
Uh, Alien Gunk, brand new individual sub. Thank you very much
for subing to the channel. What's up, Alien Gunk? Thank you.
Thank you. Keep calling him Kev99 GH. You can come and join the
stream. You are Discorder banned. I'm going to give you a week
timeout. You can get it undone by joining the stream and making
your point in VC instead of just taking your weird gay little
snipes from chat. Good luck see
limp spineless out of here. Don't compare me. Okay. We are not
the same. Wait, who is he saying to someone? They're not the
same. Who's the comparison to I'm harassing them? Absolutely.
What do you mean? If I if I have that position towards somebody,
I'll tell you why. I'll give you my explanation for it, but I'm
not going to say pretend that I don't. Okay. Like a little
limp spineless out of here. Don't compare me. Okay. We are not
the same.
Does he not understand that the comparison is like Destiny is
worse? And he's like, "Yeah, I'm way worse. Why would you compare
me to these people? Yeah. No, that was the whole idea of the
tweet that you're worse than these people. That you're worse
than Hassan. And Dan sticks by and does a stream with you. Yes,
idiot. How How does he do moments like this? Like he just didn't
actually understand what was being argued at all. That's literally
the point. Oh, what? Hold on. What is this
all over social?
Uh, he's lying for Jessica and Clement. I'd kill him if I But
I choke the house into it. Um, but not for Anna. I do want somebody
to logistical though or laugh or Mr. Girl or Quimman. This guy's
out of his mind. So he wanted to me pathetic. He doesn't want
people to know how upset he actually gets when you call him fat
and point out his He just doesn't want to be really upset
when we go over his science takes cuz he's been upset about that
for the last two days which is great. I am so excited for you
to do that with Queen here, Kelly. For you to give Destiny his
chemistry tutorial with Queen in the channel. I'm very statistical
is gonna go AFK. No, I'm gonna make you learn too. Everyone,
I'm gonna force everyone to learn. It's going to be a It's going
to be a science lesson so that this community is less than DG.
I will force you guys to learn.
Oh boy. We got to be less stupid than them, guys. It means we
got to put in some Somebody asked Tom why he's obsessed with
me. He says he's obsessed with me. I think it's the nose, but
I'm not act actually not. Wow.
It is the nose. It is the nose. True.
Amazing. Hold on. What am I getting sent? Okay, Ry, I hope this
is not Is this stuff we've already seen? But from the outset,
from the very first filing in court, is this the same? What an
unbelievable
This guy, I guarant [__] tea you that this dude went
into the Amazonian rainforest with 15 Shaolin monks to train
his throat for months to be able to take every single inch of
that orange spray painted down his throat so that he could come
out here and show us how good he could suck his daddy off on
stage. Wait, was that a compliment?
Oh my god, it's hard. That's hot. Okay.
H. H.
This guy is
on one. Okay.
I don't know if I even had anything else there. I was just like,
dude, I Oh, also I just want to say with that college student
thing, sweeping is not necessarily saying you're not doxing somebody.
Sweeping would be justifying it without actually giving a good
justification. Like when you said you feared for your life because
this person wanted you egged, right?
going that's awesome. Yeah. Like like that would be sweeping
if they go oh yeah that makes sense, right? Or like when you
say these two people um they're coordinating with Kiwi Farms.
They get all their narratives from Kiwi Farms. They they're they're
participating in my docs and like doxing me and swatting me.
So I want them, right? And you never provide any evidence. And
other people go, you know what, I don't really need evidence.
I trust you. That's sweeping. These are both examples of sweeping.
So don't say you didn't sweep it or people don't sweep it. They
do. They look the other way. They all look the other way.
We hear Kelly's lecture on salt.
Possibly. I think so.
I was kind of hoping, you know, anybody would want to join and
hop on the stream or whatever. Oh, Kelly, you didn't say that
you were on stream. What the hell? I literally just I put on
my cam a while ago. Sorry, I forgot to mention. My bad.
I'm wearing a skirt so people can't yap at me about putting my
legs up today. You guys
Hold on. Here we go.
This should work, I think. Yeah. Wow. There it is. Boom. How
do I want to do this? This. Ah, this Yeah, this works. Okay.
All right.
Okay. There's a Kelly, there's a message for you from the king
of town. You want to read that? Uh, sure. Let me just find it.
I'm not reading that. No. Also, he's spam posted that at least
a couple of times. Hi, Kelly. I'm a 6' 3, 210 lb moderately
is interested in finances, technology, video games, Linux, memes,
music, old macro media, flash cartoons, JTO, 480 plus BPM, break
core, powerlifting, economics, arguing for 10 hours on 4chan,
fat matures with massive knockers. Jesus Christ,
Sonic the Hedgehog, and Joe hit me up. So dumb. So dumb.
Jesus Christ. Really should not really should not reward that
kind of behavior at all. Really should not. Really despicable
stuff to tell you the truth.
Okay. Oh my god, guys. If you like the content, this is my first
show of the stream. Okay. If you like the content,
I want you to go ahead follow on kick follow on Twitter x.com/jlk
with an underscore. Let me go grab that for you guys. x or sorry,
twitch.tv/jlk
with an underscore. It's an underscore in both because I hate
SEO. I think it's a fake concept that doesn't exist. Okay, follow
me on all platforms and if you really like the content, you like
the stream going longer later into the night, you can donate,
okay, to add more time to the stream. We are
$12, so three subs away from another hour on the stream. All
right, you can donate through Twitch. Oh, two subs away actually.
You can donate through Twitch. You could give primes on Twitch.
You can sub on kick. You can give subs on kick. You can TTS.
You can buy TTS messages through Kickbot or through Streamlabs.
Exclamation point. Donate in the chat. gives you both links.
All right. Every dollar you spend goes to more time on the stream
except for the Patreon.
Guys, go over to the Patreon and sign up even at the free tier.
People give random gifts to people who are signed up in the free
tier sometimes. Pre-stream postream content at the tier and so
much more. The Patreon's where it's happening. Okay. If you like
the Discord, you like Discord perks, you get boards in the VCs
and and you know access to gen chat when I decide to shut it
down because you guys aren't engaging with the tweets. Okay?
So, go join the
tweet. Check this out. I had I think I had this deeper tweet
up on stream, didn't I?
Unless it's just a brand brand new one.
America tour. That is rude. That is incredibly rude. That is
Oh, why is it not just a picture of me? That is
Okay, Kelly, that's wild. Kelly, that was a traumatic trauma
that nobody got for some reason. No, I got the call back.
Oh boy. We don't joke about that here, Kelly. That's really gross.
I will just be That's like a totally banned meme. That's like
a totally banned meme here. Gummy verse donated $10. Aloha.
Aloha, Gummy Burst. Thank you for the 10. I'm going to add another
hour to the Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Oh, sorry. No, two
hours to the stream. Oh, what am I doing? Ripping you off. Another
two hours of the stream. Thank you for the 10, buddy. The thing
is that I saw a chat called Chief Louie make basically that same
joke but like the opposite of it about Kelly the other day and
it was somehow worse than
worse. Obviously worse
Yeah. Wait, do you not understand it, Like as in I'm being gangbanged
like I What is the opposite?
What would be the opposite of someone that was a lot, right?
Hey, look. He's sweating in chat now. He's sweating. He doesn't
want he doesn't want too much attention brought to this. And
of course, we all understand that Queman is very very cleverly
diverting from his obsession with Kelly Jean that has existed
for years and years and years and is well documented in spicy
chat, right? That's what he's trying to divert over Louis right
now. We all see it happening. We all see it happening. Okay.
So true. So true. I did misspeak and therefore the joke doesn't
work. But it is also the truth. So it's not even a joke. It's
literally just facts. Go get Okay. Uh, now I can just invite
people to send me the messages. Okay. If you've got messages
of Queenman referring to to Kelly Jean from the past five years,
go ahead. Send those to me now. Thank you. That is insane. There's
no I'm pretty sure there's nothing I wouldn't I wouldn't say
standby, but Okay.
Where are we going next?
Is it science time, Kelly? Are you going to teach us all about
sodium? Well, just sodium specifically, but uh, sure. Uh, I mean
I also linked just clips. There are in some of these videos that
I've linked to, he is doing other yapping, some about you. So
I if you want to watch the whole thing, we can also do that in
some of these, but it's up to you. Okay. Kelly
Kelly wants us to cover Destiny's misunderstanding of chemistry
and why he is Okay. That's a misunderstanding of a few different
things. Yeah, apparently. Yeah.
Do you think if I should I just start like making basic statements
of fact to see how far my haters will
leave? He doesn't want his science
That's incredibly up. He actually just knows that I got sent
a bunch of the pictures. Okay. BB Poison. We read this at the
start of the stream about 40 minutes in or so. Read it. Loved
it. W that W that guy.
Thank god for that guy.
Contradict me. Is that the next Is that the next play?
Just didn't I thought he was at least a little bit smarter than
he I didn't think he was as
I don't know why I didn't think he was stupid, but just like
some of the things that he said lately. They're just like completely
unrelated. It's like when he pointed at the periodic table and
called sodium unstable and volatile, I was like, "Oh, okay. This
guy is actually and doesn't know anything." And the more he speaks
about literally any subject that he hasn't spent. By the way,
I I did not like I didn't pay attention in chemistry. I think
I got a decent mark in high school chemistry, but I did not take
like a lot of chemistry. I don't know anything about chemistry.
So, if you hear me say, well, I have no idea about that. It's
cuz I'm a like weeks or do you think do you think so? The only
thing I would expect here is there's no way Destiny would spend
time trying to prove that he was correct over Kelly, right? There's
no way his ego is fragile enough that he'd have to go and prove
that he was correct and three times. I think when she's thinking
sodium, she's thinking like um do do you think she's thinking
of like table salt
because that's a compound he's trying to figure it out himself.
Yeah, I said fluoride and not sodium as well, but I mean it's
from it's from the
fluoride isn't in the periodic table. He means florine.
He does this several times for some reason. Oh, well, we love
a panic queen, Kelly. Thank you. We do. What do you call this?
Like, do you call them columns?
They just put an element in the water. That's crazy. Do you call
these columns?
See, a good start. Group. Okay. Group. My bad.
Oh, but also florine is not in the same
No, it's not in the same group. It's just simply in the periodic
table. He said fluoride.
Yeah. So, but even if you meant florine, I didn't say it about
uh like
sodium. I said it about florine or Yeah. He mentions
florine
and says uh this is my side, I think. Well, he kind of floats
over Neon and Florine, so I don't know. Okay. Wait, did he float?
There's no way he moused over Francium.
Hold on. He like looks He really is very lost. I don't know.
Uh is he like he cuz he's going to argue that things in this
group like I was arguing about florine but it's the same group
or whatever right it's not well he said fluoride but he clearly
didn't because he was trying to correct on compound anyway right
so but then he went down he was like where's the f that I was
talking about
it's not how it works yeah ping again
directly into the microphone grim is taking so long
she said that to her there is a difference between unstable and
No, there isn't. I said unstable and reactive. Oh, and he doesn't
know what that unstable is radioactive.
And he doesn't understand how those two things are connected.
They are the same thing. So, he's further showing his he's further
showing his ignorance here, guys. Wow. Groups are columns that
are more radioactive on the periodic table. Maybe they are, but
I've never heard that before. Or I mean, it might be true. I
just I don't know anything about that. Reread it. Read it again.
You guys are going to learn. Okay. You don't want to be said
that to her
Okay, I'm helping you not be this guy and reactive. Oh, I mean
I guess maybe maybe like unstable might imply
Yes, unstable is radioactive.
Reactive is two things combining.
Two very different terms in chemistry. The bottom side is similar
things.
Oh, isn't everything in that column? Hold on. What does he I'll
read the chat
Do you mean to say florine or fluoride? I meant to say flu ride
or die in your Oh, yeah. Doesn't know. Um, one of those is the
element and then one is a
molecule with a No, it's not a molecule. Maybe. Which one is
the florine or
It's an ion. I don't remember now. Now you're making Oh, is it
really ionic bonds? Ionic bonds aren't considered over there
to be a molecule. Ionic bonds, metallic bonds,
some compound bonds.
But coalent bonds usually are. So like all you have to do here
is say, by the way, just so you guys know, okay, all you have
to do here is say, "Oh yeah, I don't know anything about chemistry."
It's probably wrong, right? That's all you got to do. But because
it's Kelly who said it, he's got to dig into the stream segment.
And Kelly just likes to highlight that. Okay. So, just so I want
you guys to remember what we're doing this for. That is the entire
reason. The only reason why we're doing this is because he's
bothered by it, right? I I would not be doing this otherwise,
but the fact that he spoke about this three times and also in
DGG twice as well. It's just It is fight driven. Yes. But I also
want to make sure that you guys are not this stupid cuz he he
liked the stream himself. Was it before the stream? It must have
been before the stream. He linked the streamable himself and
was like, "Wait, am I not understanding something? Isn't everything
in that column of the periodic table highly reactive?"
He didn't say reactive, though. I have a clip of him saying,
highly unstable, highly volatile. Sodium is not unstable.
100% of all of like the sodium you find on Earth is the stable
isotope
of sodium. There is only one naturally occurring unstable isotope
of sodium and it is trace amounts. Every other
isotope of sodium, yeah, is man-made synthetic. We use one for
like PET scans and that has even that only has like a half life
of two and a half years.
Okay.
there all of the sodium you're ever going to see in your life
is stable, but it's also a compound. Like it's salt, right? Salt
is a compound.
Is she thinking of the elements that we've created that only
exist for
Is she actually retarding? No, she's not. No, the
the compound.
Okay. The iso, sorry. The isotope there is an isotope of sodium
which is unstable. Well, there's like 10 or so, I think. I can't
remember how many. All of those are radioactive because they're
unstable, right? You would not want to turn the sodium that we
use for PET scans into salt. But you could you could make a compound
salt of that same sodium. But if you ate it, you'd probably get
cancer. So I wouldn't recommend it because it would be emitting
radiation, right? Probably don't make radioactive salt. Wouldn't
be my recommendation.
Yes. I just said it's a compound. BB poison. That's what that
is. That's a sodium chloride is a compound.
Kelly is different, guys. Are you Kelly does not think that that
sodium by itself is the same as sodium chloride. Yes, I'm saying
I wouldn't recommend making that compound and eating it,
but you could if you wanted to. Although, you might get a bit
in trouble doing that. But anyway, yeah, Gay, do you know that
the weird ped pedantry Kelly's talking about here?
I'm not being pedantic.
No, you are being pedantic, but it's because Desty's trying to
call you when you're correct, right? It's like you know the technical
details of something and somebody's like, "Oh, you're" and so
you're like, "No, no, pedantic would be pedantic would be pointing
out something that's not important within the context of something.
The things that he's saying, I believe to be important,
so I don't feel like I'm being pedantic. I am bringing this up
to annoy him because it's annoyed him."
But I I'm not being pedantic and or
Unstable and reactive are like two entirely different things.
Like unstable is like the the nucleus, right? And uh reactivity
is the electrons. Yes.
These are two different things. One is chemical reaction.
Yeah. I I don't know. That's not being pedantic.
You can't you also say you've got an imply that you might be
pedantic and get into a pedantic argument over This is not pedantry.
This is teaching because he doesn't know the fundamentals of
the things that he's speaking about. There's also another reason
of why I wanted to mention that but that's fine. Oh, I just No,
this is just funny because this is just incredibly funny to me
this would be nothing if Destiny could just go, you know what?
I didn't really know what I was saying. I don't really know.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Words have meaning. Exactly what that guy
said. And scientifically, the meanings are more important colloquially.
Okay. If you use um reactive and unstable in a sentence, you
could they would be interchangeable.
Which is why if you were to Google is sodium
um stable, it would probably say no because it's reactive.
because it doesn't differentiate
uh between these two terms because it's an AI bot that doesn't
understand what you're saying.
So yes,
Kelly, don't misspeak. Otherwise, you will never live it down.
Have I done so
Why would I? Cuz I know what I'm talking
We continue with video. I think so. Yes. Go for it. Oh, there
he is.
What? Oh, he had to he had to Google Florine to find out where
Florine was on the
Does he not have eyes?
He literally literally
say nine and then he goes, "Oh, there it is."
What do you want in Okay, here. No, no, no. Here. No, no, no.
Don't run out again. No. Here. Look. You can have the bathroom
door open. Here. You're not There's literally nothing in here.
Cat's trying to save him from speaking further. This cat has
tried to save him so many times. It is. It's not. Oh.
Yes. This guy is He's picked
That [__] is what? What? I understand not knowing
what a lot of other elements that we really don't see in real
life mean. But like some of the stuff that you interact with
on a daily basis, I feel like probably you should know how works.
OMG, Destiny doesn't have the periodic table memorized. That's
not what the criticism is. The criticism is when he goes, "You
know what? Uh, Kelly's wrong. I wasn't talking about sodium.
I was talking about fluoride." And it's like he doesn't know
where it is on the table. His argument, I believe, was supposed
to be, "Oh, it's part of the same group." But he didn't know
where it was on the table. It's not even on the table. That's
why it's funny. Why it's funny. It's so silly. Yeah. Lori turns
the frogs gay. Damn true. You guys are so mad because I'm making
you lovely people. Now, the dagamites. Yeah. Maybe that was that
was the end of Okay, that's going to do it. Thank god. But there
was another clip.
Okay, there was another clip. It was most of the video today.
I think there's one more clip apparently.
Let's go.
It feels like if you're part of my community,
you're you're right here.
Oh, this was the original video, but I lithium, sodium, potassium.
She said, "Okay, is it this next one? Hold on. Is it this next
one?" Oh, I hated Kelly for a long time. end quote. Who hangs
out with people IRL? Is this Is this the one? Wait, which one
do you want, Kelly? You got to tell me.
Um, I mean, we can watch that one since you've already pressed
play. Yeah, they hate strange man. Just makes him look weird.
Not me. Does she not remember? Didn't we go over this at the
time when I went to that hay uh hay festival thing in in uh Wales?
She literally invited herself to that. Like, what the [__]
She ruined my whole I wanted to talk to the Penrose guy. She
ruined all of it. Oh my god. Me. Oh,
what was what was her
question? I had some because I s I listened to an hour of him
and another person another physicist talking chance that Kelly
understands any of that. Was it about the double experiment?
If so, that's
Can you imagine saying Kelly didn't understand all of that when
you thought fluoride was on the periodic table and you called
sodium unstable.
You're like, "Oh, Kelly is the one that doesn't understand things
here. She couldn't possibly I wasn't talking about the double
split experiment either. I was talking about another duality
in particle physics." And I linked him this article
to and try to explain it to him, but he was too dim to understand
what I was saying. But I also wasn't having like an argument
with him at the time.
it's just he walked off mid conversation,
but also it was a public event that I wanted to go to anyway
because Xjek was there and I stayed like longer and went to go
watch his thing the next day. Uh, and he also messaged me before
I went cuz I I messaged him saying, "I'm thinking of going to
this event." And before he left or maybe just as he got there,
he messaged me saying, "Oh, are you coming or are you there?"
One of the two. So, I feel like if you didn't want to see someone,
you probably wouldn't. I don't know. Just saying.
Yeah. Why does Kelly has to have this will to come off super
smart there? Okay. Nothing I've said really
in any in the last 10 minutes or however long this has been has
been anything you wouldn't know if you weren't asleep during
like high school
science lessons. I don't You learn what a compound is when you're
like 11 or 12.
I I I don't know what to say. The fact that he doesn't know like
basic
doesn't make me smart. It makes him stupid. I'm pointing out
that he is stupid, not that I am smart. Okay. I'm just saying
anyone that paid attention in school would know most of these
things. I don't
Okay. So, is that is that everything here, Kelly, or we continue
going with this one? You you tell me. You're the person. I don't
know what you're if you want. I mean, you could just watch this
video overall. It's not that long and it's got like some mentions
of other in it. I don't know. Do you want to do that and just
watch the whole
We want to watch the whole thing. Sure. You know what? Let's
watch the whole thing. Let's do the whole thing, Kelly. So, reaction
to the obstacle
too much science cuz I feel like everyone's getting mad. So,
there you go. Kelly, teaching us will ultimately be the downfall
of your I have no idea. I can't correct her and I don't have
enough of an ego that I have to be like, "No, I know chemistry
well enough to say she's correct." I'm literally just never going
to have an opinion. It can't possibly affect me in any way. Except
people leaving because they don't want to listen to Kelly talk
about chemistry. That's the only way it could affect me. And
I don't If you guys think I'm wrong about something, just at
me and message me it.
I will respond to you.
I uh who cares if Kelly is correct.
I do cuz it's funny. We like winding up Destiny and making him
see.
Kelly's on stream. Kelly cammed up. Kelly's helping me out. So,
Kelly gets some time to explain what she thinks sodium is to
people.
I should just
I'm just proving that he's wrong. He said a lot of things that
are wrong whilst looking smug and trying to seem smart. And also,
just mostly cuz it just makes him mad. He wouldn't have spoken
about it three times in the span of two days if it didn't make
him mad.
That's true.
Okay, here we go. I'm trying to nestle this in. Good. If there's
anything in this video you don't like, I guess you can skip it
through it. But yeah, it's like he's not a sociopath like Destiny
is. I'm a sociopath. Just like give me one DM. What? What is
the most sociopathic? What? Cuz of the DOS kid again. Do we just
have to pull like I literally pulled the four screenshots up
from the Anna thing? Give me one DM. Hold on. It's just important
to do it like every time. Okay. Like basically every single time.
We just We could do it. When Dan calls him a sociopath, he doesn't
say anything.
But when I do it, it's a problem.
Like it's annoying that I have to do it every time. But yes.
Yes. When somebody is upset and they're continuously like having,
you know, spirals over the same comment you make, over the same
concept, right? And you say, "I'll fix that for you sometime.
But for now, just until then, you can work on your essays on
your bed while I rub your legs and feet, okay? While you have
a foot fetish, okay? You are you are sociopathic. You are a weirdo.
You do not you know do not care or understand this person's emotion.
You do not care about helping them. That is that's pretty weird.
Pretty weird.
Pretty strange.
just one log there. Well, there's the log right there. There's
There's the Destiny, have you seen the way that people are covering
the recent Unveiled drama? Kind of wild seeing the defense that's
being run with by communities that accused you of doing the things
that came out. Yeah. Just remember it's the it's the By the way,
we didn't accuse him of We didn't accuse him of anything like
this, right? There there was no accusation that oh, you tried
to have a relationship with somebody who had a mental illness
and it didn't work. That there there is no accusation of this.
It's the resonance the res the propaganda resonance model. All
of it is like it's all of it is very intentional the way that
it works. Remember, the goal is always to fixate on me and to
try to like spin a certain narrative and then to deny, deny,
deny everything else. And like meanwhile, in the back end, they
have like the power of Kiwi Farms, you know, working as hard
as they can um with them. Why Why do I just get I get saddled
with Kiwi Farms, I guess. Okay. Which is basically a community
that can post with impunity whatever they want. So like two people.
So literally, by the way, this entire idea, this entire concept
he's introducing, I have no idea what he's talking about. I'm
guessing it's just a way to say no, I have no proof of this,
but of course I don't have proof of this. But look, I have a
name for the phenomenon that I'm saying happened. It's literally
like, listen, this is the the propaganda resonance model is just
renaming the deep state, right? Oh, the deep state. It's it's
literally just that. Hey, I'm going to connect things that I
have no evidence for and I need an excuse to do it. And I know
I like absolutely torched anybody who allowed conspiracy like
this into their mind before, but now I want to do it really badly.
So, I'm gonna I'm gonna come up with a fancy name and then I'm
going to go ahead and say, you know what, that's okay. Now, conspiratorial
thinking, that's base. That's awesome. We're cool. We're so cool.
We're so awesome.
People that are like barely even supportive of me. Uh they have
like super omega. Yeah, we uh we're going to pull the Dean Withers
clip shortly, guys. Uh or tried to dox just to try to like push
them away from
there. So, he's assigning blame for that on like people like
me, people like Kelly. I had nothing to do with that. I disavow
that. I do not like that. Okay. I don't I don't want people to
be menaced from giving their opinion. I want everybody to just
give their opinion and then we could like discuss them, right?
I want anybody to be menaced away from giving their opinion or
to be harassed directly being supportive of me. And then meanwhile,
and it's funny too because generally in a Kiwi Farms thread,
like if anybody's being cringe, like they're going to post about
it. Uh they'll be like, "Oh my god, look at this cringe guy."
Like if you were in a DSP or a Boogie, whatever, you know, KF
thread, if anybody around them is being cringe, they're going
to post about it. But in my thread, it's so funny cuz if you're
like, if you're one of my ops, they will run so much defense
for you. It ising hilarious. They're like, "Look, look at Justicle.
He's defending himself against Destiny's slander and his horrible
comments." So like all of Yeah. Destiny just maliciously lies.
like you uh if you wanted to just take what um like the the public
tweets made, right, and say, "Oh, I believe that wholesale this
guy forever." I'm okay with that, right? I'm not going to I'm
not going to try to convince you otherwise. You could do that,
right? But that's not what he's doing. He's saying things like,
"Oh, this guy said mentally having some mentally ill people is
he's the only person who's ever made a comment like that, by
the way." Right? Can I pull this Can I pull this clip? Hold on.
Would I be able to find this clip? We had this clip yesterday
of him talking about this. And the funny thing is is basically
Lav asks him point blank, "Hey, if you had somebody who's like
mentally ill and in like a spiral of sorts, would it would they
be able to consent to interactions with you?" And he goes, "No,
probably not."
And it's like, "Oh, so you just described Anna and why she couldn't
say no
here. Why she kept interacting with you?" Oh, interesting.
Wow.
Hold on. Let me let me pull that. I'll go back to this video.
No, no, no. Hold on. You guys actually have to sit here in silence
while I pull this. It won't take me too long. I think I've got
it here
he does bring that in this video. This is funny.
no. You're coping. That is literally No, that has to do with
porn because it enforces an idea that this is like No, I think
I have to go back. Great. But do you think that mentally ill
women who are caught in feedback loops are able to consent? No,
they're not. That's why I would say it's probably immoral to
have partner with mentally ill people. But I wouldn't say the
is bad. And I wouldn't say with women is Oh, okay. Interesting.
Huh.
I don't think I've ever taken that Can't say I have either.
yeah. I don't think I don't think that's uh that's not my position.
I have like the clip with Tom Fury. With Tom Fury, I'm trying
to describe a specific behavior and they clip like 30 seconds
of this out to say that uh like it's but one, it's like not a
very good allegation to begin with, right? It's unironically
like a co because people are just with him and he gets really
mad about it. It's unironically like a co. So it's not a very
good allegation but there are a lot of other elements that are
going on there anyway. So he's the person who said this and mentally
ill people who are caught in feedback back loops. Can they consent?
What was this if not a feedback loop?
Right? What was it if not a feedback loop? Any comments on Destiny's
new stance on Kelly Gene? I.e. He kept Kelly Gene around because
he knew that cutting her off would cause her to become an anti
fan. Antifan number one like Anna. No, that's just totally made
up. It's obviously He literally said in his in his chat, "We
looked at a log the other day and now it actually would be super
relevant." Oh, hold on. I probably have it here. Hold on. I like
I probably have it. Yeah. Like it's just total cope, right? Uh
Mr. Mutton, honest. Ah, my windows all just went away. [__]
And this was very much after the whales event and every other
event where I've seen him at too. Sorry. Sorry.
As you can honestly know, as much as I disagree with Kelly Gene
on basically everything, she's honestly a really good person.
Like I I think almost pixie levels of being nice courties to
people.
Um this was
less than a year removed from him
her non-consensually to random people. So cool.
Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. of them work on the front
end of like this powered off the back end and they don't want
to get on the bad side of people for some reason whatever most
of the commentary people are too scared to even mention they
call it like the forbidden site they won't even mention the name
of the place but um yeah that's just the it's just the way they
operate so I think people like um I don't think common and everybody
are like desperately trying to move the
Freudian he must be watching a lot of this guy's videos when
he's cammed up He's Quimman's biggest fan when Quimman's cammed
up. And then Quimman shuts the cam off and he's like, "Oh, I
hate this guy. I hate him. I hate him. I hate him." Away from
Jessica because it's not relevant. It doesn't matter what he's
done. It's totally different. It's not even comparable. Like
remember,
it literally is not even comparable. It's It's not even remotely
comparable. Destiny people remember the guy. Remember that guy.
And I was like, "Uh, okay. Sorry. I keep forgetting I'm on this
account not trying to take over your chat. Um, listen the you
can take over whatever you want, buddy." Okay. Oh, and I saw
another thing. Remember the every accusation is a confession
or whatever. I realized
literally the thing we all criticize Willie for, right? The thing
we we all basically get annoyed about is when people try to break
these things up into individual events. It is a pattern of behavior.
That is the chief thing, right? It is a pattern of very very
immoral behavior of what you call like sociopathic like totally
lacking empathy. Behavior that totally lacks empathy over a decade.
It is a pattern. Now, why
in all in her little side discords and why Kelly calls herself
Destiny is fat. For some reason, like four months ago, she became
obsessed and then all of them became obsessed with this talking
point that apparently I've gotten massively fat even though I
think my weight is I don't
massively. You just got a big gut that kind of un overhangs your
like trousers. It's not pleasant to look at. By the way, I don't
think I ever call this guy fat. I don't think I I'm literally
like the first time Kelly did, I was like, "Oh, I think I'm probably
fatter than this guy right now." Like, I I don't know. I can
see him like on camera. I don't know. Calling you fat. I was
like, I I might be fatter than this guy right now. And then Kelly
started calling me fat, too. And then she calls Nicholas fat
all the time. I don't know. What do you want? What do you want
me to do, bro? It's not an obsession. They're talking. But they
This is the point they have. And now, because Kelly can't keep
her mouth shut ever,
when people found out who Jistle was and pictures of him started
to leak, um, apparently he started to freak the out. Um, and,
uh, Kelly was like trying to like coach him in the background.
Well, he thinks I coached him over you being fat. I didn't even
get this before. He totally misunderstood this actually. He didn't
understand what this was about at all. Oh,
unlucky. Oh, boy.
I was lally saying you should go to the doctor and work out and
you'll feel better and you'll like feel less emotionally unstable.
By the way, and then I did that and then I did start sleeping.
Yeah, it was awesome.
Jessica's still spending time doing night classes in the school
of around and find out he's still just a man. Jesse's fat as
Kelly. When Jessica was spiraling in like February,
he was leaning on me. So, you know, someone is not making the
best decisions doing that. I literally told him that he should
talk to Wolf Gang or Queen. I spent hours talking that mofo down.
By the way, I told Kelly I was like, "Kelly, why would you say
this publicly? You're like so I I was like I I just don't understand
what this what this does. This is so
I don't care because because weird. It's just so weird to be
like, "Oh, this person was DMing me a whole bunch. They they
came to me when they were like feeling really bad about certain
things going on in their life that were making them like vulnerable
and I was like you know what it's true when I tell people this
oh my god the alternative is that you're a cold sociopath that
was using a BPD woman and I'm like no he is basically a BPD woman
from the edge and he did do some of the things I suggested at
the time like working out more and going to the doctor eventually
unfortunately cuz nobody sees this side of him publicly it's
going to come across as though he's like Kelly will do this and
then she's like, "Wait, why do you clear our DMs? Wait, why do
you clear our DMs? Wait, why do you clear our DMs?" This had
nothing to do with our DMs. We had this over VC and I wasn't
leaking VC recordings, was I? So, this is just things that I
remember with my brain. What does it have to do with DMs and
took advantage of you sound stupid when you said he is not I
like uh it literally was in our DMs as well. Oh. Um,
I didn't
If I wanted to leak DMs, I would do Hold on, Kelly. You understand
that there's a concept where you can describe what's in a DM
without taking a screenshot of it, and that is leaking the DM,
right? You're saying I delete my DMs because you might leak them.
As if my brain doesn't remember things and I need to use your
DMs. But these were conversations had over VC.
Like that's what I'm referencing when I say spent hours talking
that mofo down. Why do you feel like maybe didn't have I I don't
even want to ask more questions because I don't really care right
now. It's like not actually my focus. But this is
it's so
it takes strength. Okay. There is nobody as powerful as me being
able to like sit here and be fine with this. Okay. You okay?
Would you rather I just let people sit there and speculate over
you being an abusive psycho instead? Is that what you prefer?
I'd be like, "Yeah, that's probably him." Why? You'd rather people
think that you're like a cold stone psycho and not just like
an unstable male? Yes, that's better. Is it? Why? Because I don't
like people knowing my personal feelings on things.
That That's worse.
Also, like it goes against the argument that you're just like
trying to take advantage of someone because I don't know. It's
just weird. I don't know. Also, I know I knew the situation,
right? So, from my perspective,
if I'm going along with the narrative that you're abusive, then
that means that I co-signed the abuse by knowing that this was
a thing. I don't like that either.
That's [__] All right, I'm done. I'm done talking
about it. I'm going to hit play I backed it up and I'm going
to hit play across as though he's like stabled and took advantage
of a BPD person. He is not. I like how um the the argument that
they're trying to run with now is Jessica couldn't have taken
advantage of Cherry because Jessica is also insane. Like that's
the that's the
uh not as insane as this game. Not anyone's that's also like
shouldn't be anyone's argument probably running with
the cop is just like insanely hilarious.
further and say he needs to build a stronger support network
entirely external to this online space for the sake of his sanity.
Oh, also I I like how they all talk like Trump now, too. They
do this in my Kiwi Farms thread. And uh
why does he think we talk like Trump? Oh, doesn't he? Wait, is
this a video where he brags about how he like got somebody into
Kelly's Discord to take screenshots? I heard about that one.
Public Discord that can join
with no join. just speaks like this and they'll type like this
where they'll make like a statement with like a exclamation mark
and they talk like
Does he not realize that? Because it's funny. Does he not real?
Does he not realize
Jessica, don't do that. I need Cherry here to scream at you for
when you do that. I miss her. Anyway,
now I forgotten what I was saying. Oh, I have the username Destiny
is fat because when people screenshot it, it shows up like this.
So, if I cared about screenshots, I wouldn't have this name everywhere
because he has to read it That's also true. Yes, I know. It's
also true. I don't think he's realized this. It's funny just
how badly it bothers him. Like that he has to correct it to everybody.
He like actually he's actually like so upset about it that he
has to go, "Guys, they obsessed with me being fat even though
I've like not gained any weight at all." I go for saying he needs
to build a stronger support network entirely extra.
Sorry. He's not as capable of getting under my skin because literally
everything he relies on is a lie. It's like, "Oh, Kelly must
be fat now and has double chins." It'll be like some other ridiculous
thing he says each time. And it's like so obviously not true
that I just I don't know. It's like, "Oh, I could just put my
cam on and prove this not true."
Like everything he says
like I I'm not going to get bothered by like fake
And he's already brought up like the worst thing you probably
could. So like what is left? You want to talk about my vagina
being sewed shut or whatever? I don't knock yourself out.
Well, I don't know. Sake of his sanity. Looking for guidance
and support in all the places that will lead to inadvisable behavior.
I have told him this too and encouraged him to see IRL friends
and reach out. Him and Cherry are honestly very similar in this
respect. Is Destiny as fat as Kelly Jane? Yes. I didn't realize
he was so emotionally affected by this in the background. Why
do you every time? By the way, the him attempting to dox me is
like taking up like no bandwidth.
Um, this was
ah, no, I'm not even going to say what it was.
Um, there were like a lot of things going on at the same time.
Uh, this was this was like the other point in my stepfather's
chemo. This was like the worst point in my stepfather's chemo.
And it was like
out about Yeah, it's uh But you know what? I kind of shared it
once in a while.
No, no, no, no more. I just He's
Yeah, it's no more. But I'm just saying that's like that was
a huge thing weighing down. I think I mentioned it once in a
while, but like him posting a picture like nothing. No worries.
Which why I reference it today. Was emotionally unstable because
I had to deal with him spiraling in voice chat for weeks despite
the week before him behaving like he hated me. LaMo, this wasn't
just about Cherry. Obviously, the stuff that happened at the
end of January had a negative effect on him because Destiny started
to attack him. I love the framing on that. Like out of nowhere,
I just started attack. I don't even know if I was attacking me
at the end of January when the Pixel drop. Didn't I take like
5 days or a week off? Well, they all
What's that, Kelly?
I didn't say it was out of nowhere. Whether it was January or
February, I mean, who cares? Like ran their Victory Labs. I think
it was probably I think it was probably more like if he was just
attacking the things I was saying that would be totally we're
all good right if he was commenting on commentary but then he
was like no I'm going to try to dox this guy
I'm going to I'm going to call this guy's death and it was those
things those were the things it was like oh I thought there were
like lines here but there were no lines oh these were some of
just arguing with people in spicy chat and chud logic's discord
trying so desperately
Sunday did you see the tweet where Cherry said they sent Quman
all their data on Destiny no justical I find it very interesting
that Willie Mack, this is also somebody that KB Farms is trying
desperately to dox um and are trying to apply a bunch of pressure
on it. Totally disavow that. That really sucks. Hope they don't
do that.
I By the way, it sounded like I was saying that passion. It's
just more that like that's an obvious take. Like I actually genuinely
don't want Willie to suffer any like harm or be scared to give
his opinion on the internet. I don't think that's appropriate.
I don't think that's ever appropriate. People will amplify it.
Yeah. I find it very interesting that Willie Mack is more interested
in dancing on my grave than Cher's comments on her police case,
which are basically, by the way, unchanged for the past 7 months.
But,
uh, no, I think she said she just talked to her detectives, right?
Hold on. See what else we got here. Uh, didn't Willie have extremely
harsh things to say about Destiny? Uh, it doesn't matter if you
have bad things to say or not. You have to you have to buy into
the narrative, which is that I
intentionally mind manipulate women, turn them against each other
to fight. I'm going to leave the criticism of Willy's because
I get some gratification for it and that I intentionally hold
on
on what's the which is that I allegation
intentionally mind manipulate women turn them against each other
to fight with each other because I get some gratification for
it and there's evidence for this the Zoey I intentionally hunt
for um people who are crazy or intentionally hunt for people
who are mentally damaged so that I can take advantage of them
and so if if you have other criticism it doesn't matter you have
to buy into that narrative or else these people endlessly witch
hunt you, kick you off servers, whatever else. Quote, I hated
witch hunt you, kick you off servers
for a long time. To be fair, like I like I don't think he goes
out of his way. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. I do know what
that mean. No, no, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on. I do know
what that means. I think that means that Yogi is one of the people
advising him.
Endlessly witch hunt you, kick you off of servers.
Is Yogi not messaging this guy about stuff? I feel like he almost
certainly is. I've seen him in DG chat try to feed Destiny lines
as well. Oh boy. What What does kicking you out of servers mean?
Why the would that be relevant to witch hunting or doxing or
something? Kicking you out of servers.
I'm honestly confused. Uh don't worry if you don't if you don't
get the reference. It's fine. You don't get the reference. No,
I I I remember who Yoga is. I'm saying it.
Sorry. Oh god. I'm saying it chatters. If if you don't get the
reference, it's fine. I see.
Is that a Y? No, Yog got kicked. We just we just got rid of Yoga
because honestly he's just an energy vampire.
He's like unbearable. That's That's so funny. That's so funny.
Sorry, Kelly. I cut you off. Do you want to make your point or
do you want me to rewind it? I forgot. It's fine. If I think
I'll be If you have other criticis, it doesn't matter. You have
to buy into that narrative or else these people will endlessly
witch hunt you. I don't even think you have to buy into the I
don't think there's any need to buy into the systemic targeting
of mentally ill people. I think it's more of a filtered concept,
right? Like like by nature of like who this person is, they attract
certain people and you just filter down over time. But it's uh
it's actually not really relevant at all. It's the continuous
the consistent perpetual and habitual violations of consent.
Um and basically not considering your partners like people in
so many in I will Yeah. I will also say like I think that he
could probably make a mentally sane person mentally unwell.
I think I I think Molina didn't have any mental illnesses at
all, but the amount of that she went through, she was obviously
really stressed by the end of it, right? Yeah, sure. Tolerated
a lot. I think that the amount that a lot of the people that
have been around him have had to go through would uh put a mental
strain on a lot of
Yeah. But I also think it's not necessarily that he goes out
searching for like mentally ill people. It's more like I don't
think he has any
there's no like there's no care for the people, right? There's
just like they're just somebody that are there to use in some
capacity. So it's like
I don't know. He doesn't care about them as human beings is more
accurate I feel.
Um what's the stuff Lauren keeps saying? Also just the actual
like totally ethically unquestionably awful conduct of sharing
of people without their consent and of recording people's without
their consent. Obviously those are the major ones that you're
getting currently like kind of canceled for about you recording
people in your It's like I have a hard time
some click with a button. I have a hard time feeling like he
could really care about the people involved and especially when
he's saying how nice Pixie is and how courteous she is and like
speaking so positively of all of those people and then just them
over. It's like yeah that's what if that's not sociopathic behavior
like having so little regard for the people you're supposed to
care about then what is? I don't know. Damn. Uh, so when Lauren
says that over and over again, she's referring to one conversation
that I recorded between me and somebody else that had to do with
a lot of Molina stuff. Again, in my mind, if somebody's going
to me over, do some really weird shady up. Maybe theoretically,
I might record a conversation, you know, just cuz I want just
to if for no other reason to go back through my own personal
records to see what people have said. Okay. Um, the way that
Lauren keeps saying this is that like is implying that I'm like
recording me people or recording me like like stop or something
like that. I wonder what it could could have possibly given her
that impression. I um that's how she like implies it. I don't
know if she's going to say, "Oh, I didn't imply that. I mean,
he was a nasty person, just like a mean bad person or whatever."
But I'm like, "Okay." Um but yeah, that's when Lauren says it
over and over again. That's what she's uh that's what she's referring
to.
apparently they go through the screenshots from Spicy, pick you
off servers, whatever else. Quote, "I hated Kelly for a long
time." End quote. who hangs out with people IRL. They hate strange
man. Just makes him look weird. Not me. Does she not remember?
Didn't we go over this at the time when I went to that hayfield
uh hay festival thing in uh Wales? She invited herself to that.
What the? She ruined my whole I wanted to talk to Pros guy and
she ruined all of it. Oh my god. Me. What was what was her question?
I signed an hour of him and another person another person talking
and then we got to chat. She went up she asked a question to
prove me wrong on something that wasn't relevant to any. Can
you explain my friend? I'm like are you serious? Like this is
like a kind of a worldrenowned physicist. Is it about the double
suit experiment? If so, that's even funnier because there's zero
trans understand any of that. I didn't have the time either,
but
tell me
um the motivations bunch of
or for destiny. Obviously not true. But it's funny that it lives
in his head ran free.
That's what bothers him. And he did get to speak to the guy.
So I don't know why he keeps blaming me for that. He queued up.
He asked a question. Then a little girl queued up and he spoke
to that girl. And I queued behind her to ask a question.
So, I don't know, man. Guess everyone else is supposed to, you
know, give way to Destiny and his
questions. I don't know why he would have even had to ask. I
don't think that's true. Like I said earlier, she might be complaining
the mining for info initially and his desire to keep things quiet.
Him inadvertently causing harm or abuse is not what we're talking
about. When Disfield does that, it's inadvertent, but when I
do it, it's part of the designed plan. He pursued a married woman
with
uh I would say, what would you say in this case? like the endless
loop it seems like of inadvertentness. It's like I I don't know
how many times you get to claim inadvertent, right?
But also like just the general like conduct is just different.
Like totally different. But history of mental illness while engaging
in warfare like
um like totally just seek h I can't man I unfortunately I don't
even know if I want to keep going through this video because
I already said I'm not discussing like the the stuff anymore
any dynamics. You can skip through parts of it if you want to.
I don't mind just uh let me just see where the rest is and
there is anything else here. It's that I unless you had something
specifically you wanted to go to.
Also, the ops Discord is imploding. By the way, this is all Kelly's
Discord. This isn't my Discord. Does he think it's my Discord?
It is.
Yeah, it's like just mine.
uh the rest of it doesn't matter that much. He he does talk about
lab and stuff like further on. And what does he also Yeah, I
mean if you don't want to go the screenshots, you could just
skip ahead a few minutes or something. He comments on where that
even came from, but it's not interesting at all. We know who
butters his bread, but you Jesus man, you're just destiny if
you needed other streamers for success. I like how I'm the sole
oyster upper upper of Willie Mac's career. But yeah, well-known
Destiny Orbiter Willie Mack, who survives on all the clout that
I give him. I think for Dan versus on Chris let us stream. No,
he totally survives almost entirely on uh on Nicholas, but um
I feel like I scroll through parts of it, but was there anything
interesting that came out of that or is your main criticism of
Destiny that he has relationships with his peers in streaming
or that he has with people with personality disorders? My Destiny
said exploit people's vulnerability for his satisfaction to their
endangerment like you've done clearly. And now it's obviously
turning
I think he does take advantage of vulnerable people. They're
not necessarily cuz they're mentally ill, but just like vulnerable
in some way. Like Molina was young and I don't think she really
knew better. I think that was the way he took advantage. So that
is like absolutely what it is.
To maintain opportunity. Apparently, if you have to anybody who
has any kind of mental or personality disorder at all, I guess
all of that is exploitation. Do you think these people should
No, it's not all exploitation. Like wards of the state. What
the does that even mean? Wait, Jessica, so according to you,
Destiny is leading. It would be something like Okay, like here
would be here would be how this would work. Okay, you had to
somebody who had let's say like um some sort of mental disorder
where if you were like cold to them um if you if you were like
really detached about your relationship with them, they might
have like really bad uh episodes or freak out or something, right?
That would be hypothetically. And then you know you're a cold
uh avoidant person and you are willing to have them hook up with
you knowing this and then you're willing to continue that relationship
and go cold and avoidant and like cause him to freak out or something
would be like an
that would be like an example. And and probably that's just what
the criticism of Destiny is in a lot of these cases like the
Anabar thing, right? So you you like know this is actually like
destroying her mentally, right? that she's being considered a
stalker by people instead of saying, "You know what? I actually
really like this person and I talk to them all the time in DMs.
I do have a close relationship with them even now." Right. Yeah,
that would be an example, right? Like I Yeah. No, they're not
crazy. We do we do have like a relationship. No, I'm not going
to go into it, but yeah, we do have a relationship and no, she's
not crazy.
Like Anna Anna was being publicly crazy made, right? So Anna
is saying, "We have a close relationship." And Desi is going,
"I don't know what this [__] is talking about. I
don't know what this is talking about. Right. That's that's like
the difference here. You're perpetuating
Yeah. It's like using the the
parts of the illness against them specifically, right? It's like
weaponizing it to hurt them.
Being an infinite machine because he has something. Infinite
machine is Sunday's hypothetical that I only referenced on stream.
If you saw that out of context in a video and didn't ask questions,
you may be almost as the video's creator. Oh no. She recovering
from right until you found out the recording of Cherry. I had
no romantic or relationship with Cherry before or during any
of the Destiny coverage. Hold on. See if I got anything else
here. Did you ever see president live tweeting through your Cincinnati
spent like he was a kid watching his friends at the playground?
Maybe. I don't remember. Oh, Lava is trying to jump in too. Cute.
Turns out Jess is the real past. Not only does he surround himself
with women who have orbited destiny, but he also manipulate them
and date them. What's up?
Uh Kingler asks, "Does do you feel slighted by his logs?" I assume
the answer is no. You just didn't want to talk about it. But
I didn't even read his blogs.
Some of them were on the screen when you wanted to skip forward
cuz he was making
Well, I just
that topic and it's like I I'm good.
Yikes. And then our good friend Les into the fray. Yeah. Too
bad he's saying the only thing he accused Destiny of which is
making them fight for content, exploiting their personal drum
online, and distributing the one without their consent. Keep
in mind that this claim, which is like the central claim, um
meow that like L Mr. girl so desperately want to respect. There's
never been any like proof or evidence of this ever. Like notice
how there's literally proof with Lav and Zoe. I don't know why
he just lies. He just like openly lies for no reason.
Literally Destiny had a relationship with Zoe. He had a previous
relationship with Lav and he was feeding Zoe. He was literally
saying like you need to go post like a picture of yourself here
cuz your skin's so cool. It'll make life
literally trying to start a fight between them. Hi Kelly. Also
Annavoir is the first one who laid
successful 38-year-old man who is interested in finances, technology,
video games. Shameless donation, by the way. Absolutely shameless.
I don't know why, but
sorry. Go ahead now, Kelly.
I think it's Anavoir that made that accusation originally, right?
That he pits the girls against each other in some way. It was
like a pre-existing It might have been slightly different, but
it was like a similar thing that pre-existed the Lav and Zoe
fight. It's just with the Lav and Zoe fight, we have more evidence
of it happening, but I'm pretty sure it was an accusation that
existed before, but I can't remember what Anna said. I don't
know if you remember, but it had something to do with when Mr.
Girl and that were like talking to her and like when Yeah, I'm
I'm pretty sure those accusations existed then. People forget
he directed his herum to join the Discord. Dude,
ever since Lav left, you know, orbit, she still fights with everybody.
Like the idea that you would have to force Lav to fight is like
saying you would have to force fluoride to react with something
like if you put her in any
fluoride again.
Why?
Also fluoride fluoride is not it's he means florine florine's
in a different group and yeah oh florine is an element. Fluoride
is not it's not it's I I'm sorry. Like the chemistry thing is
funny just by virtue of how badly he's triggered by it. Like
it's not funny at all. It's just incredibly funny
once you realize he's like so upset about it. Like so angry that
he will it will stay in his mind. He will continue to see about
it. Fighting everybody always. Like that's literally what she
does. It's part of who she is. He definitely makes mentally ill
women fight for contact. Also, he's accused people. Is quite
reactive. Yeah, but that wasn't what they were talking about
for being predators. Florine is the most reactive chemical on
the periodic table. Fluoride isn't. Boride's like mid if you're
going to like look at a reactivity series and compare it.
Forine
the most reactive.
He's an idiot is what I'm saying.
Damn. Mentally ill women. Oh, she Oh, I was going to say what?
But he's talking about Jessica. Jessica's now a self-admitted
predator. He doesn't them and make them fight for content. Having
a long history verse one that he's trying to handle gracefully.
Okay. You're either a brain dead drooling reach or you're doing
this obviously to cope. Choose one. I don't give a about any
of these people because I'm not autistic and ugly like all of
you. I have no dog in this fight. You're so insecure about Yeah,
I was going to say I was going to say this before she even said
this. Uh Lav won cuz I think this person's a woman. Mantis. Yeah,
the um whether it's an AI woman. How how quickly before Lav pulls
out the physical attacks because Lav will always go to other
women.
Mantis just got hgalled. Mantis just got totally hgalled.
I you know I get I get where he's coming from though. Okay. Because
I think that might be a trans man and maybe they were like jerking
off into a camera. It was just meant to be shocking and gross.
Okay. It's like a trans man with large breasts or something.
Yeah.
Yeah. I think so. She used to be able to pull out her mega successful
marriage and husband too, but she can't do that anymore cuz she's
Oh, trans. It might be trans trans woman. I I forget what the
line is.
literally destroyed every single aspect of her life now. All right.
All right. Okay. This cool. I guess that's cool.
I got to yell about science for a little bit, so it's all good.
Watch the Chud video. No chats. I watched a Chud video personally.
I am not watching the Chud video on stream. I did try to address
some of Chud's criticisms when I did the stream coming back.
Uh I wrote them down and tried to address them. If you want to
go watch that stream, that stream was two days ago. We are done
with that topic. Kelly asked me to watch that video. I did a
favor for Kelly. Okay, cuz I'm nice.
If you ever seen me on an IRL stream, my party trick is reciting
the periodic table.
That was before I was a child before I had the internet. So,
I don't really have much else to do.
It's not impressive for me to do it now because you could just
be like, "Well, you're reading it, you stupid bitch." Which would
not be very exciting. I'll be real. I prepared no other content
for today. So I and probably I'm gonna keep going. We'll figure
out what we're doing. But I I prepared no other content for today.
So yeah, all those people whining about Kelly wanting to yap
about science.
That's why
ended half an hour ago. Dan and Nick fight. We did the Dan and
Nick fight already. We did the whole Dan and Nick fight.
This is an anime filler episode. We're doing our best. Okay.
We're just It's a fill. I said party.
Jesus. That was not smart. That was not smart at all. Are you
smarter than a Kelly Dream game show? Collins. Uh,
the thing is I haven't said anything that anyone that isn't very
stupid would like disagree with. I really don't like talking
to stupid people. Like I'm always the first to leave when there's
like a chatter that doesn't know what's going on.
So I
I don't know.
All right. I literally don't know. We could watch the uh Spooky
Sunday. Okay, maybe. Oh, Dean. Reich. I've got a bunch of Dude,
this Dean clip's apparently unhinged.
Let's see. Is Dan Is Dan going to go after Dean?
Oh, Dan could go after Dean. Hold on. Let's check it out. This
Dean clip is apparently crazy. Dean clip is crazy. All right.
Yeah. Yeah. Hold on. There's a There's a Dean clip. That's wild.
It's out of this world. Let's check it out. Let's go and take
a look. Dean Withers orders his fan base to dox a father and
report him to CPS for saying that children aren't able to
If I was dumb enough to send my kid in, it's no different than
a baby commercial for diapers. Can you answer my question? Do
you think that you have the right to consent to 65year-old men
looking at your son while he's naked?
I wouldn't allow it. Do you think that you have the right Do
you think that you have the right to allow it? Do you think if
you did allow it that you would be violating the consent of your
child?
They have no choice in the matter whatsoever. It's my decision
as the parent and I wouldn't put my kid in that situation. That's
why I think pageantss are weird in the first place. I would It's
such a pedantic thing to get like super triggered about. No,
no, no. Don't do the JTO soy. Do the uh the Parker soy. Yeah.
It's literally It's literally like the same face. The hand is
just like slightly rotated. Okay.
I thought the point is that kids are unable to consent because
they are literally children. They don't really have agency because
they're babies and we have to do things for them. I don't Like
basically being done here the guardian like a parent basically
can say no this is good for you right and they have that right
like technically I think even like legally right a guardian has
that right you can get like if they abuse or fail to exercise
that right appropriately they can lose that right but that is
like basically assumed so he's just saying like I could do this
because I would I care about my kids like he's not he's not saying
he would like violate his kid he's saying I explicitly wouldn't
do that but technically it's my right as a father So, so like,
yeah, hold on. Did somebody mention the Nirvana? Yeah, the Nirvana
album cover. Yeah, you absolutely have the right to do that with
your kid to say, "Oh, well, this is an artistic thing. I don't
think this is like I don't think this is harmful to them in any
way." Like, if the photographer is 65, like apparently, yeah,
boom. Right.
But basically,
you'd hope you hope society, I guess, corrects that. I don't
know.
Anyway, it's I mean it's like weird. It's a weird circumstance,
but I don't know. It's like discussing the ethics of like child
actors or models or something. I don't know. Well, it's like
I don't know why this guy is so hanging out about this. I don't
the Nirvana may be sued once they were an adult. Oh, that's interesting.
But I don't know. Like I don't know if they were wronged. They
could feel wrong as an adult and like sue to get the album cover
like not used anymore. But I don't think they were like wronged
as a child. It would have like affected their development or
something. How would they have even known it's just a baby?
I assume they were told so.
No, I mean, no one else would know. Like all babies look the
damn same. Yeah, I assume they were told, you know, But also,
too, cuz I assume the rights were given up at the point because
like is the photographer has the rights to the photos. Well,
it sounds like he lost. So, he probably didn't have the right.
They lost. The baby lost. Baby didn't have a
No, the baby lost. The baby lost
once they were obviously lost.
Yes. What? What are you saying? The baby. You mean the adult
lost? When? Yes. The But they're the baby as an adult.
Yes. Of course they would lose. They don't have the rights to
the photos because they're not the photographer. There would
have been a model release form signed. Well, yeah. I assume so.
But it would have been the parent who signed for it, which is
part of the argument. Hold on. He's talking about Trump being
in the changing room of the young girls. Uh Dean noticed the
guy had a child in his PFP. Dean asked how he'd feel if Trump
did that to his child. And he said the guy said, "I would never
do that to my child, but it is my right to put my child in a
pageant if I want to do that." Which means putting them possibly
in a changing room where there could be like an adult in there,
I would guess, is how the argument went. So about it is weird.
Okay. Are we good? Can I hit I'm so confused. Yeah. Okay. What
the? Hello. They weren't suing over copyrights. He's literally
just sitting here soying. He's literally He's sitting here silently
sawing out.
What were they?
Sorry. What were they suing for? That's not what this is about
table. Sorry, I'm just asking the chat person, brother. You've
got no other content. Why are you complaining I'm dragging it
out another 10 seconds?
It feels not
relevant and I try to cut away irrelevant stuff, but you know,
you are the one that brought that up. It's not Somebody told
me it was and then you wrote it up. Whatever. Yeah. Okay. Are
you going to continue talking about it or you can if you want?
I don't know. I don't have anything to say. I asked someone in
the chat
and I didn't. You have no choice in the matter whatsoever. It's
my decision as the parent and I wouldn't put my kid in that situation.
That's why I think pageantss are weird in the first place. I
would watch how long he sits here silently for. He's just silent
the whole time.
He just continues to remain silent. Guy's actually the worst
person.
This is like so incredibly annoying.
Okay, so here's what we're going to do. I I think that you don't
deserve to have uh any custodial rights of your child.
Wow. Cool. You get to determine that. For those watching, their
handle is Goatman 91096.
Um, it's going to be their dude. The text can't be correct. The
text has been correct so far. There's no way. He's just like,
"You guys need to do something. Something got to be done about
this guy. Look, here's his handle. Looks like he got a picture
of his kid in his profile picture. Something got to be done about
this guy."
It's going to be their handle. Well, if there happens to be anybody
in here that's good at like has like facial recognition software,
uh, or that's fine. Nothing I said was wrong.
I just said that the kid doesn't get to make the decision. What's
your name? Would never put them in that situation. Okay. What's
your name?
And why are you trying to dox people, dude? That's weird. Because
I I want to find who you are so I could call CPS and have them
take your child away from you. Oh, I'm sure I'm sure you would
like to try to do that. Yes, I would. This is
insane. Also, I thought the color got kicked, but he just sat
here silently with the collar still there. So, uh, they would
never even do it. That's the best part. Okay. What's I would
take the part and I have a witness sitting here who's heard me
say I would never put my child in that Okay. So, so, so what's
your name? So, don't worry. Move the goalpost, too, by the way.
So, you said that you think that parents have every right to
exploit and traffic their children. So, no, I that's not what
I said. So I'm not